我跟我现在男朋友感情就是比较比较好，
但是因为我年龄比较大一点，
所以我就是打算在做那个重大的决定之前跟您连个麦，
然后寻求点建议，
本来呀，
我们俩打算就是这个月再婚登记来的，
然后呢，
她那个前段时间发烧了，
因为我这个男朋友吧，
她身体怎么说呢，
平常检查啥问题没有，
但是就是一年可能发这个烧吧，
他就可能要烧好几周，
然后最后文可能是得上医院打激素，
然后就好了，
但是其他时候啥毛病都没有完，
各项大的检查，
查什么拍CT啊，
骨川呢，
嗯，
没什么问题，
他这身体我也确实害怕，
因为他确实是他没有孩子，
他就一定要要这个孩子嘛，
所以我就想着这个，
昨天跟他也商量，
我说你这个身体这个情况吧。
我说我有点害怕这发烧可大可小的，
这要是光是结婚我能照顾你，
这要整出个孩子来，
你说我将来怎么照顾你，
他的意思就是说你现在主任吗？
我这个是我这个身体算是有毛病了，
怎么回事儿了，
然后现在就在这一块，
嗯，
出现分歧了，
不管是他呀，
还是他他的父母啊，
人都挺好的，
然后呢，
也都特别喜欢小孩，
我能理解他们，
但是因为我也是想来评论区，
一个是看看大家的建议，
然后也是想听听你的建议，
我怎么能最大程度的保护自己的权益，
也是不想失去，
就是我也想我要是跟他分开会怎么样。
但是也是有点不舍得吧，
也觉得遇到一个这样的人，
一旦分开，
可能这辈子也不会遇到一个再有再婚打算，
这个遇到这样的一个人了啊，
也挺纠结的，
我这边是有孩子的，
他们有孩子，
你这边孩子现在多大了，
上高中了啊，
现在基本上都自立了，
跟他爸爸还是跟你啊，
跟我，
我从他出生，
他爸概然后就是我一个人也带大的，
其实是，
所以我这块没有问题，
孩子都很支持，
也很支持我再要孩子，
那样子你要是比我年龄还大一点的话，
就这个年龄要孩子牺牲挺大的。
对，
然后我前段时间去备孕，
然后也是做各种检查，
他也知道，
我也跟他讲了，
我说年，
你找年轻的话，
人家可能胖，
可以这个东西可能会种多一点，
那我可能就会少一点，
但是不不代表我少就是不优质，
但是我得让你知道，
你肯定找年轻的会更好一点，
然后他的意思是说，
因为他的条件，
找一个年轻的女的结婚生孩子肯定也不是什么难事，
因为我们俩家条件还都不错，
然后但是他觉得可能我要是做，
他是如果说给他孩子将来找母亲的话，
他希望嗯，
我是这个孩子的母亲，
他可能觉得对我，
对我更有安全感了，
或者是觉得我更能做好母亲这个角色吧，
然后反正我该跟她说的，
她其实也能接受，
就是即使哎呀我可能也不太好怀孕，
她也知道这个事儿，
嗯，
但是不是代表我不能怀孕那种哈，
就是人家也愿意跟他接受这种风险，
但是他就是有点挺执着的，
我就要小孩儿，
我就要小孩啊那种，
我再婚了，
我也不打算，
我肯定不想再离婚了，
他原来分手原因是两个人异地了啊，
然后啊，
然后那一年的女的有了，
有人了，
然后就分开了，
这样子，
哎，
我也挺纠结的，
也就是说他一发烧就发烧一个星期两个星期这事，
两个星期两个星期就是他发烧这个过程当中他有。
什么表现呢？
他就上不了班儿，
然后他情绪上有什么问题吗？
发烧这个问题，
但是是不是上不了班，
但他都是在央企，
还好一点吧，
顶多就是早扣点钱，
那他平均比如说一年像他这种症状的话，
发烧发两周，
两周上不了班，
大概能发几次呢？
一次去年也是年初的时候，
今年也是年初的时候，
就这事儿，
一发烧发两个星期啊，
就得去打各种激素是吧。
一直打那一针激素就好了，
然后我问过大夫，
我说大夫他这个打激素不就人体不好吗？
大夫说他这一年才打一次，
你什么事儿没有，
那意思，
也不知道是大夫是见多识广还是怎么样，
病号见的多了，
我就因为我会比较恐惧，
因为这个发烧可大可小，
哎，
我就有点害怕，
嗯，
那你有跟他比如说去查一下，
比如说查一下他的小蝌蚪的质量怎么样，
查了没有问题哦，
备孕了吗？
因为下个月都查了，
然后其他的都查了吗？
比如说呃，
各种传染病啊，
各种啊，
这个这院都有查，
对传染四项啊这些什么您那个东西，
然后我知道的，
因为我们人比较有法律意识啊，
然后这些东西我该查都查，
就是都没毛病，
然后我还跟他前妻还联系了，
你知道吗？
他前妻还说了他，
他说他特别喜欢小孩，
且他父母也特别人特别好，
他说我就觉得也是因他这个事情对他父母嗯，
不太好，
然后就是觉得对不起他父母，
他说但是他的身体来讲的话，
就是感冒，
说各种检查也是根本就没有事儿，
你说这不能算什么问题吧，
他的前任倒是挺想得开的，
反正就是说话，
就他就这么说的，
完后我就当时说完这些话，
我就决定行，
那就跟他登记吧，
都约好了时间了，
结果他又发烧了，
前两天我就陪着他，
因为我。
很愿意去照顾他，
但是照顾他的同时我就在想再来一个负担的话，
哎呀，
我真是觉得这基个本，
所有的负担都在我身上了，
那你这边自己的经济条件怎么样呢？
我家也有三套房子，
没有贷款，
他家也有三套房子，
也没有那个什么债务债务什么的，
都在央企，
年薪两个人都是，
嗯，
接近20万吧，
就一共40万的，
父母都都央企退休的，
反正什么其实养个孩子应该是没问题，
就是质量好质量坏的个意思吧，
我感觉你们这两家也是门当户对啊，
两家也是属于小康家庭，
经济实力也摆在这儿，
你是在一线城市，
如果都两家都有三套房子的话，
就看你自己，
如果你真的觉得这个男人性格呀，
嗯，
脾气呀，
各方面啊都跟你很合拍，
就是我们做最坏的打算，
假设这个男生身体有问题，
假设他去的早，
然后你自己带着孩子，
你觉得有一个他的基因，
他的性格，
你能养得起，
也能接受，
那就继续往下走，
他跟我的意思是说，
哎呀，
你要是生的时候，
我要真有点什么好歹，
你要不放心的话，
你就认为我父母真不不会成为你的累赘什么来，
话不是那么说的，
那当然真正自己的孩子，
你说我能一点不管你这事儿，
我感觉你那个还是2。
人一起去做一个基因检测，
看合不合拍，
还有个基因检测可以做的，
对，
就是说嗯，
这事儿我也我也不是很专业啊，
我大概用我能理解的这个语言讲给大家听，
就是有的两口子他感情特别好，
我以前直播间就来过，
他和他老婆感情特别好，
但他俩呢，
就是属于基因，
每个人，
我们每个人的基因都会或多或少的有一点缺陷，
如果说我的基因，
比如说从1~100是50~60这个地方有缺陷，
然后我老公的基因从1~100也是50~60这个地方有缺陷的话，
我俩要凑一堆了的话，
那就回回都胎停，
回回都流产呀什么的，
你明白这个意思吗？
如果哎，
我我我老公他从1~100，
他是89，
或者说87这个地方有问题，
但我是二十二，
二十三这个地方有问，
我俩凑一块儿的话，
生出来小孩儿就没啥问题，
大概就这意思啊，
可能我讲的不专业，
但是大肠不差就就也好啊，
就是这意思啊，
你俩去测一下，
别说不行的话就能好了，
然后哎院再测一会，
就说你俩觉哎就是说也不是说不能结，
不能生，
我感觉哈，
我感觉人家也通过各种各样的检查了，
也没有什么传染性疾病，
没有什么遗传性疾病，
也没有什么身体其他机能没有什么问题，
他就一年发两个星期的烧，
然后这个发烧，
这个烧又是能控制的。
然后你本人也喜欢他，
也爱他啊，
而且两家家庭条件都很好，
两家家庭经济实力都摆在这儿，
孩子也不会过苦日子，
我感觉这个也没啥，
嗯嗯，
好明白，
好谢谢你，
嗯，
好，
再见啊，
刚刚有很多说人说啊，
一年发一次烧啊，
呃，
怎么怎么地的，
其实现在这个社会啊，
找一个心理很健康很阳光的人本身就不太容易，
可能我是干这个工作时间长了，
见的实在太多了啊，
你找一个性取向正常，
然后审美正常，
然后有正常同理心，
同情心，
有正常人类的感情，
能够心疼你，
能够体会到你的不容易，
感受到你的受伤，
感受到你的那个委屈，
完了之后心里还挺健康的，
没有什么太大的心理疾病的，
我感觉能找到这样一个人就着实挺不容易了，
你很难要求一个人完美，
要求一个人啥毛病没有，
很难的，
真的，
姐如果实在是不放心的话，
我觉得还是做一个全面的体检。